das ist wohl der ramadan kuchen doch mal
das passiert
wirklich von optiker mega süß megaschön
und vom geschmack ja da wird pistazien
markt der ist hier genau richtig
[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es endlich
einen pistazien kuchen haben sich so
viele von mir gewünscht und ich habe
letztens als sander nicht im urlaub habe
ich auch eine story gemacht von in einem
café von einem pistazien milch kuchen
mit einer creme schicht oben drüber und
haben sich direkt für inspiziert und
gesagt was wir anders machen würden und
aber das ist es auf jeden fall meine
inspiration für dieses video und ich
brauche jetzt zuallererst mal einen
fluffigen pistazien boden ich habe jetzt
hier schon mal eine küchenmaschine falls
sie keine küchenmaschine haben nimmt
einfach ein handrührgerät dann braucht
ihr nur ein zwei minuten länger aber das
funktioniert auch wunderbar und wie
immer schreibe ich euch alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben und infobox ich
leg direkt mann los ich habe mein ofen
auch schon vorgeheizt denn dass der
boden gibt sehr schnell sie beziehe die
eier die ich einmal direkt in die
schüssel geben und da kommt gleich
einmal zucker dazu und wann immer
extrakt und dann wird das ganze vier
minuten lang richtig schön dick cremig
geschlagen
[Musik]
so die eier zucker masse ist jetzt
soweit fertig bevor wir weitermachen
zeige ich euch aber mal wie wir mit den
distanzen umgehend für dieses rezept das
habe ich hier einen mixer ihr fragt mich
auch ganz oft wo ich dem heer habe das
ding ist das haben wir mit 56 jahren zum
geburtstag geschenkt und er gibt auch so
langsam den geist auf und er wird auch
schon seit jahren nicht mehr produziert
aber habt mit sicherheit irgendein mixa
zu hause also auch in dieser dieses
musik sowie würden jetzt auch
funktionieren hauptsache die haben so
ein hauptsache der mix einsatz drin der
schafft das so ein bisschen feind zum
nächsten es muss auch nicht so perfekt
sein ich gebe jetzt zu hilfe ein
bisschen mehr hier mit rein und dann
kommen die pistazien dazu denn ich
möchte dass das die wirklich mit dem
dass sie mit dem mehl 1 werden kann
jetzt mit da rein und dann wird das
gemixt
[Musik]
so das ist jetzt quasi unser pistazien
mail und bei dem start ziehen unbedingt
beim kauf darauf achten dass ihr
wirklich frische pistazien kauft es gibt
natürlich auch zum beispiel solche die
kennt ihr wahrscheinlich alle aus der
bug abteilung die riechen und schmecken
einfach ganz anders als richtig frische
pistazien weil hier ist meistens auch
färbemittel mit drin und vom geschmack
her schmeckt es einfach nicht intensiv
nach pistazien ich verlinke euch meine
aus dem shop die sind auch der pistazien
stadt gaziantep alle typen wissen
bescheid ich gebe jetzt aber zuallererst
mal die zerlassene butter die sollte
jetzt nicht so heiß sein sich in der
mikrowelle zu lassen hier gebe ich nur
mit zum teil so dann kommen die
trockenen zutaten dazu also hier noch
die restliche milch ich mache jetzt
einfach so dass ich das vorab kurz hier
mit dem restlichen pistazien meter rohre
und ein bisschen backpulver darf nicht
fehlen das kommt jetzt wie gesagt gleich
alles mit zum teig dann noch ein schuss
milch denn nur so kurz wie notwendig
unterrühren und eines der teig fertig
[Musik]
den teig habe ich ganz zum schluss noch
in der farbe pistazien grün eingefärbten
ihr wisst ja das auge isst immer mit und
auch in dem café als sowohl aufwand das
wurde 100 prozentig eingefärbt und das
ich finde das auch vollkommen in ordnung
weil wie gesagt das muss auch richtig
lust machen auf mehr wenn man das schon
sieht und dann habe ich noch meinen back
rahmen mit backpapier eingeschlagen der
teig ist schon ein wenig flüssiger und
daher ist es immer von vorteil wenn ihr
das so ein bisschen mit backpapier
einschlag wenn die so ein bisschen
verlust hat und dass ein bisschen was
raus läuft ist das okay das muss man
immer also das ist halt immer absehbar
dass muss man einkalkulieren ich habe
jetzt hier auch mal auf das backblech
genommen achte darauf dass ich schön ist
gerade das backblech verwendet damit
halt wirklich nicht viel ausläuft
dennoch nehme ich so ein bisschen
gewölbt ist dann ärgert ihr euch das
soviel ausläuft aber so sieht man also
jetzt sogar gar nichts bei mir in dem
fall und jetzt werde ich es einfach nur
ein bisschen glatt verstreichen und dann
bei 180 grad ober und unterhitze
komplett gebacken
[Musik]
während des tages den kuchen nichts
kümmern wir uns schon mal um die
pistazien milch dann hat man hat ja
gesehen dass es in so einem bett von
pistazien milch lag der ganze kuchen und
es gibt ja auch im türkischen ganz viele
rezepte wo man den boden quasi einfach
richtig trinkt mit mit milch oder mit
zuckersirup und so würde ich es bei
diesem rezept auch machen und ich habe
jetzt dafür das habe ich am vorabend
gemacht es braucht immer so 45 stunden
die pistazien in wasser eingeweicht in
der franz normales kaltes wasser zum
vergleich vornehmen und einreichen
aussehen also so da hat also ist ja noch
die haut dran quasi und die habe ich ja
gerade auch mit verwendet das kann man
auch ohne probleme machen wofür die
pistazie ich wollte ich die gerne ab
machen wenn ihr keine zeit habt dann
überließ das gerne einfach mit kochendem
wasser dann braucht es nur eine halbe
stunde oder so maximum aber mit kaltem
wasser gibt er den pistazien einfach
zeit und das ist einfach für die für das
aroma einfach schöner
[Musik]
ein kleiner tipp noch wenn ihr die
pistazien einfach nur zwischen daumen
und zeigefinger drückt dann geht die
schale wie von alleine weg guckt euch
bitte mal diese fahr ich komme gar nicht
mehr weg vom grinsen das ist also hier
ist keine künstliche sättigung drin also
klar man bearbeitet die video so ein
bisschen nach
aber ist das nicht erst krank einfach
nur krank ich werde das ist ganz das
ganze jetzt so pistazien milch
verarbeiten hier habe ich mich dann
nehmt euch wieder einfach irgendwann
dass man so ein bisschen mehr rein und
pistazien mal gucken ob ich jetzt noch
mit pistaziengrün nacharbeiten muss weil
ich glaube jetzt farblich kommen wir
bestimmt hin und ein bisschen
puderzucker
[Musik]
so die pistazien mich selbst fertig und
ernährung peter offen 25 minuten hat das
ganze gedauert da kommt ja auch nicht
erst mal kurz an die seite der darf sich
abkühlen also der kuchen kommt an die
seite nicht mehr offen der offen bleibt
wo er ist und jetzt kommt noch mal eine
leckere creme am top kämpfe auf dem
video gesehen da war ja auch eine
grünliche creme daher kommt jetzt eine
pistazien creme ich habe jetzt die kalte
schlagsahne schon in meiner schüsse
allgemein sind jetzt alle zutaten aus
dem kühlschrank und ich gebe jetzt zur
sahne direkt puderzucker bei puderzucker
habt dem man den vorteil dass er sich
einfach schneller auflöst daher auch
gerade bei der pistazien mich kein
kristallzucker sondern gerne puderzucker
verwenden und hierzu könnt ihr dann
gleich seine fest ein riesen das nicht
aber so ein bisschen an schlagen also
ein bisschen an mixen und so weiter dann
merkt dass ihr immer fest gerne seine
feste zu gehen nicht ganz steif schlagen
denn kurz bevor steif wird geben wir
noch magerquark und mascarpone dazu und
vanille extrakt darf auch nicht fehlen
[Musik]
so die pistazien creme ist fast fertig
natürlich fehlt es scheint nämlich die
pistazien creme was haben wir eine
pistazien geben das sieht ja cool aus
und schmeckt bestimmt die entsprechend
auch cool
also ziemlich genau als die hälse krems
rauskam kam durch die nachfrage was man
mit einer pistazien kredit dennoch schon
bis da zählen genauso ich glaube sind
locker zwei jahren fragte uns dass und
also manche sachen brauchen einfach
langen boot zu werden oder genau und wir
sind aber dass manche waren auf jeden
fall gut gut ding will gut dass wir
einen quoten armel mtv haben
wir auch einmal sind aber kuba ich habe
dann guck dir das mal mehr ein mann geht
echt nur
mit socken nur mit klatschen auf jeden
fall aus der welt ob stadt und das ganze
land ist auch gar nicht anders zu
erwarten also wir haben gar nicht
woanders gesucht werden gesagt es müssen
einfach das tat sie noch ganze an tipps
sind die besten und leckerste bis dahin
ich weiß es ist gerade aber das ist
jetzt vorbei geht ja wenn vorgetragen
aber ich sage aber essen und werden kann
der kann auch helfen
er war hier muss er jetzt noch was
pistazien mäßiges rein daher ist es
einfach kommt euch das mal
unruhig das ist chemisch an das wird dem
namen richtig gericht das wird wirklich
so schön sagt jetzt ordentlich von hier
in die creme rosé auch schmecken und er
haben war ich weiß noch gar nicht wo du
darfst früheren hast ja geben und so den
hand rührt ihr dann weiß ich rutsche
gemacht und so stehen chip ist es auch
sich welche jetzt also eher so eine art
bestimmt so eine art sachen milch kuchen
okay ich hoffe jetzt sei das anders und
mit erde reichen die wenig wie und dann
an macht und nicht aufbauen müssen
wiederum zeit
durch langsam so kurz wie notwendig
damit es nicht richtig wird ja mega das
reicht sogar schon damit es nicht werden
wir nicht zu viel staat kann zeigt
gruselig werde nimmst du bei seinem
auftritt
[Musik]
ich wollte ganz kurz war
richtig heftig eine kommune sind lecker
und heftig richtig nein kannst du dir
absteckt
so jetzt sind alle komponenten fertig
die creme ist ready der kuchen ist
abgekühlte boden und wenn ihr wissen
gerade unterlage nehmt dann läuft euch
überhaupt ich kann ich das gerne mal für
einen seiten zeigen wer recht flüssig
nämlich sagen und das ist das einzige
was aufgelaufen ist dann war das auch so
bezeichnen kann somit kann ich das ganz
einfach hier erfahren sie das backpapier
ich
[Applaus]
schöne grüne farbe nicht zu viel nicht
zu wenig ich lasse jetzt auch bewusst
den bug haben dran ich nehme es ja immer
nur kurz weg weil das brauchen wir jetzt
erstmal nicht mehr und dann haben wir
folgendes das ist auch wieder so typisch
türkisch ja ich nehme einen
schaschlikspieß den ich mir ja gut
vorbereitet ein paarmal durchstechen man
könnte sich doch die mühe machen den
teig draußen ihm umdrehen buck kam
wieder dran machen aber das ist auch
eine methode da sticht ihr dann einfach
ein paar mal rein damit sich die
pistazien mich den weg durch den teig
suchen kann quasi da mal ein stechen mir
sondern lieb ist ziemlich darüber geben
dann müsste auch nicht alles darüber
geben weil wie gesagt darum im café im
urlaub hab ich gesehen die haben einen
tiefen teller genommen und auch so ein
bisschen pistazien mich noch mal daran
gegeben seit optisch cool aus und ein
bisschen was wird aus treten das ist
normal da ich finde das kann man ja auch
ganz cool servieren nachdem ihr das dann
darüber gegossen habt kommt einfach die
pistazien creme oben drüber lasst es
aber ordentlich einziehen also wartet da
ruhig ein paar minuten kommt die piste
cremo drüber und dann könnt ihr noch
nach belieben dekorieren und
anschließend einfach ein bug vom löser
nehmen und einfach den kompletten wagram
lösen und dann in stückchen einhält und
was ich immer finde pistazien sind sind
erdbeeren halt nicht weit weil das
einfach ein schönes farb das spiel
ergibt und deswegen kommen da noch
pistazie nach erdbeeren on top so jetzt
habe ich es aber
[Musik]
erinnerst du dich an den kuchen ja ach
so in der migration darüber gesprochen
klar erinnerst du dich daran hat gesagt
mach
die creme so und so machen den boden so
und so ohne sieben ohne reden einfach
mal probieren wo viele aktien lieber
jürgen berg darin märkte sind patienten
also im vergleich dazu als wir dabei
waren gestern abend hat es war grün aber
es hatte so kraft genau das wollte ich
sagen das ist einfach pistazie pur der
der ur geschmack pistazie obwohl er das
hattest du weißt wo der boden zwischen
hellas im vergleich zum zusammen aber
die kommen auch betriebe die richtig
bedienstete fahrbereit gemacht ich habe
auch nur ein bisschen gemacht weil ich
mag es nicht wenn das zukünftig aussieht
aber das ist natürlich mit na also ihm
dürfte dadurch treten das ist voller
ramadan folge kann er also ich mir
darüber aber das
orientalische gucken er ist ja auch mal
was passiert das müssen stück teilen
viel doch mein eigenes fristgerecht
eingereicht hatte er wirklich von optik
ja mega süß megaschön und vom geschmack
gehabt pistazien mag der ist hier genau
richtig weil erwartet hier auch nicht
wirklich pistazien findest du klar ist
ein bisschen größer erwartet das ja ich
habe in die creme keine
lebensmittelfarbe rein gemacht weil ich
finde dass halten ist also es ist pastel
ich das finde ich viel schöner man darf
nicht übertreiben heute arbeit ist auch
ist mit allem zu viel sich gut gelaufen
ist
macht zynga eines mal lieblingskuchen
bisher und
[Musik]
probieren
wir machen so schön angefangen und
wünschen euch viel spaß beim nachmachen
leute nochmal ich sage das immer wieder
gerne dass videos vorgedreht schild
macht
[Musik]